are we live yet something we are okay
well welcome councillors to um an
extraordinary council meeting with a
couple of items on the agenda pretty
important items on the agenda but before
we begin um we have at least we have
three apologies that i'm aware of
councillor grant
councillor dixon and councillor macphail
is that right is there any others
there's not would somebody like to move
those be adopted please move councillor
bulger seconded
councillor phillips thank you all those
in favor please say aye
against the motion is carried thank you
councillors
so moving on to the very first
item on the agenda which is the adoption
of the the annual plan for 2223
and we have a memo from the chief
financial officer outlying the the
process
and the result that we've got to
and lunai would you like to talk us
through this please
just think of your worship and through
through your worship
the counselors are aware we went through
workshops earlier in the year to talk
about items that were included and
wouldn't be included in this year's
annual plan these items that the
councils agreed on have been included
which has resulted in an average
increase of 5.94 across the district
split between the various areas
the urban average increase is 6.42
rural is 4.78
and industrial is 5.94
now we in the previous meeting i
indicated that
we had an anomaly that caused us to
revisit
the figures that we'd had up for last
week's council meeting the anomaly was
has risen due to a an era with an
anomaly with our model and was picking
up incorrect comparatives i can confirm
that everything that the council has
agreed on is included
the effect of this has meant that
the matada commercial rate payers in
particular have been impacted
the rates increase for the commercial
rate payers of matara is a direct result
of the council's revenue and financing
policy which provides the blueprint for
who pays for what when costs increase in
one of the council's activities at a
different rate to costs and other
departments the policy defines where the
costs sit
in this instance
um councillors agreed to that we had
inflationary pressures and roading of
20 and we included a 20 increase in the
roading budget to maintain the current
level of service
roading costs are recovered through a
targeted rate for urban and rural
roading and sit within the ward rate the
urban rate is then further split between
residential and commercial for gore and
matara
matadoro residential and commercial
rates are subsidised by heavy industry
properties within the material rating
area heavy industry properties and total
do not pay a ward rate instead they pay
a heavy industry rate
the revenue and financing policy
dictates that the heavy industry rates
increase is adjusted in line with the
district-wide average rates increase
which is point nine four percent
this means that notorious heavy industry
rate pass will not experience the impact
of the twenty percent eroding increase
and therefore the policy pushes those
costs onto matada residential and
commercial rate payers but in
particularly the rape commercial rate
payers
i hope that's
an explanation for councils about how
we've resonate where we have
i am happy to report that the adjustment
has led to a decrease in our unbalanced
budget from what we had originally
forecasted of over 1 million it's now
sitting at 763 000 unbalanced
we've chosen to
go with the unbalanced budget to not put
undue pressure more undue pressure on
ratepayers we appreciate that it's
difficult out there and we are trying to
work in the best interests of the
community to deliver the levels of
service that we can
thank you lornae and look i'm sure
there'll be some some questions as we go
along but um before i open it for
councillors um
steve says chief executive do you want
to make any comment
on where we've ended up
uh yeah thank you look
again i think we need to take stock of
the fact that we've got a 5.94
per cent rate increase overall
with inflationary pressures being
one percent north of that figure
however what i do think it does
highlight this result is the
fact that our
current rating system is in dire need of
a first principles overhaul
and
sometimes you can be
you can iron out wrinkles and they and
they create further wrinkles and
after a period of time you look back and
you think
we're creating more inequities than
actually we're trying to resolve
and i think most people in the district
would look at
like properties
of similar value and scale should pay
probably a similar level of rates
and we don't really have that
in this district in a number of
instances
and we've also tended to hang on to
some very
long standing uh tools that have never
been the
subject of a critical contemporary
review
and so the concept of whether we should
have one rating district as opposed to
an effect 3
and differentials being imposed on
commercial industrial properties
and a heavy industrial
rating island that only sits in one ward
they are all
methods that have been
imported into the current system which
throw up anomalies that we simply
can't fix particularly when you're
outside your ltp years
where you have reviewed your
revenue and financing policy
and then are duty-bound in the off years
to administer that without fear or favor
but all those things said your worship
for the odd property that may be
very adversely affected
it's been my intention to work with
those particular owners and see if we
can come up with some type of an
arrangement
subject to council approval to
mitigate the impact felt because it'll
only be probably a select few
but we need to work with them and see if
we can arrive at a different way
of
ensuring that they pay a fair share but
not a disproportionate share of the
rating burden
thank you steve
and i acknowledge the the challenge that
uh some ratepayers in matera are going
to face and that's something we
shouldn't be imposing on on anybody
willingly uh i
you you've outlined just exactly some of
the challenges we have with our system
and the reason why we do need to address
it and at the first instance we can i'm
just not sure when that is i think
that's long-term plan
time is it
yes you worship through uh it is a
stated commitment in the current
long-term plan that we will review the
system and come back to the community
with an alternative following
comprehensive review
with
hopefully an alternative proposal for
consultation in next year's ltp yeah
and
you know i've heard the term used around
this council table over the years about
an elegant system to get a good result
and patently what we have at the moment
is not that elegant
so
as a council we need to be making every
post a winning post to make sure that we
get
a system that is
not just fair and reasonable but simple
simple for people to understand
but you know that aside i think the
the outcome across the district is is a
good outcome in today's environment for
the um for the cost that we're imposing
on the community for the services that
that are provided so um i'm keen to hear
counsellors views and open it up for for
council now
council phillips
thank you i've just got a couple of
three questions i'd like to
just to bring forward uh the first one
is
when we see in the long term plan and
the schedule of grants
that um
the free swim school primary school
project is set at twenty eight thousand
eight hundred thirty two dollars is that
including
the travel cost for materials scope to
come to corporal
is that initially what was
part of the grants that they were
to be paid
okay
can somebody answer that
question
uh thank you you're a chef and through
your worship
that decision does predate my starting
at the organization however i do believe
it does include the travel for mataldo
primary schools too
my understanding was that it include
travel
i i just have
i just have a problem that it's not
listed because it can be
taken away
and that that shouldn't happen because
it was the gorgeous the council that
shot the pool
and one of the prospects was that it
will
pay for the travel to
for the pupils of the material school to
do that
that was certainly the intent yeah
the other one i have your worship is on
page 25 and that's the future change of
the arts and heritage group
and
the the
part where it says the precinct former
library building of 150k will be
allocated in 2023
to provide seating
finance to attract external partnership
funding for the future development of
the site
um i've got a little bit concerned about
that because
what does that mean
yeah 25 was it ah yep
it's on the
paragraph of
the second from the bottom
just above the library's one
second from the bottom
um
should have been left out after
after the
council had went public with the
um
what was to be developed from the
building or what was to happen to the
building do you think it's
it should not be there uh because i have
a real concern about the especially the
last part of the of the um sentence
where it says funding for the future
development
and this council to me is not that we
have not had any discussion
of the future development of that
building
you worship the points fairly made um
my
recollection of where we got to with the
old matteo with the old live building
was that it was indeterminate um there
were three options put to
the community no one option found favor
and i think the feedback was
the
the proposals apart from demolition that
were put to
the community were not sufficiently
defined to enable the community to
exercise
a decent judgment on on the merits
otherwise of those options and so the
council committed itself to come back
with
perhaps more definition once its
thinking has evolved our thinking really
hasn't evolved too much to be fair since
that time we're still focusing on trying
to complete what we've got under
construction
particularly like the mirawa center
which is in the
advanced planning stages and due to be
tended in the next
two months
so your worship as a suggestion i think
we
should delete that penultimate paragraph
from
the precinct's former load well you
could have the pre-precinct formal
variability that's currently being used
as storage
for the
mirror i project
full stop
we don't have any firm plans to
share
with the community and it's unlikely
that will be shared
before the next iteration of the ltp
well thank you
good point
okay any
any discussion around that point any
change council davis
so the 150 000 that you've got there
what will happen to that will you just
remove it from our budgets
uh through your worship
this is capital funding so it will will
not have an impact on a rating
the actual rates increase or decrease at
this point in time because it is capital
funding
but it can be removed from
council gallon
it will oh yeah and if you go down the
next page um it's got the um
capital funding sources of capital
funding is increasing debt of 1.93
eight million it'll decrease that will
it
what page is that
page 27 27.
the second column worship yeah see that
i would imagine that would reduce that
your ship um it depends on whether we
have loan funded or rate funded that one
but it will it will it will likely come
reduce that figure
okay um good point
councilor phillips
okay uh
you wish i just got one other thing
just that uh
on the um
rate increase for the material residents
and i and i and i apologize to the
matter residents and i did that the last
council meeting
and i'm hoping that uh after the
district planning committee
um that we
come to some sort of resolution and help
out their commercial rate bars and and i
think we're working hard on doing that
it's just been a timing factor i think
it's been there a problem
but i think that sentiment is shared
around the table and and the chief
executives already mentioned that he's
looking at alternatives at the moment to
help out those that are affected
right
other issues from the annual plan that
anybody wants to raise councillors
just probably is a little bit
disappointing we haven't started um debt
reduction on the buildings the civic
building and looking forward we're not
looking at any debt reduction on the
library
but um we need to progress that in the
future because we did move a 25-year
payback on the library
uh through your worship and i'm sure
luna might want to comment but there was
a deliberate
give us a year's grace to try and help
out to come up with a as low as possible
rate increase
um and that but that certainly intention
is to
for next year
to
introduce the debt repayment program in
line with a 25-year objective of the
council
will know
through your worship uh at the workshop
that we held with councillors we did
discuss the fact of not paying down debt
on the library before we'd actually
finished building the building
so that their decision was made as part
of that workshop with councillors with
regards to the civic building we have
started repayments on this portion on
civic building part where we see the mix
as there's other projects going on that
offset it like the water so overall our
debt is still increasing but specific
projects the debt is decreasing on
great okay that's good
um workshops are discussion no decisions
are made at workshops
decisions should be made at council
level here exactly and i guess that's
really where this discussion is
happening now
okay any other councils
any issues that they wish to raise with
regard to the annual plan
does not okay
then we'll move on to the
recommendations
on the second page um and there's a
three part recommendation
would
somebody like to move that is a
three-part recommendation or
one at a time it's up to you
so councillor bulger
three
so the recommendation in total has been
recommended by council bulger as a
second to that motion
councillor reed thank you
any discussion counsellors
does not i'll put the motion all those
in favor please say aye
against the motion is carried thank you
councillors
that brings us to the second item on the
agenda which is the rates resolution and
we have a memo from the chief financial
officer uh just outlining what that
looks like and the the resolution that's
required
to be moved
quite um
exhaustive resolution i guess is one way
of putting it
but certainly all encompassing
resolution
lunai do you want to talk us through
this at this point
i think you worship through your ship i
will take it as read i i think this um
this is a standard
uh rates resolution memo that follows
the adoption of any annual plan
and outlines specifically what the rates
are for every every item and
they make up the rates good and the
resolution um meets all the auditing
standards
okay that's good
right
uh questions from councillors on the
resolution at all
does not would somebody like to move the
recommendation then
councillor heisted dive second afford
that
motion council grant thank you
is there any further discussion at all
there's not i'll put the motion all
those in favor please say aye
against the motion is carried thank you
councillors um
are pretty short but uh important
agenda that we've traversed this
afternoon
i'm not aware of anything else that is
required to be discussed now
um so with that being the case
i will declare that the meeting closed
and thank you councillors for
the input